good evening
welcome to the hillsdale college campus
here in washington dc i'm matthew
spalding
vice president of the college and dean
of our van andel graduate school of
government based here in d.c
this is the first public lecture
of the recently formed academy for
science and freedom
at hillsdale college
the academy exists to educate the
american people about the free exchange
of scientific ideas
and the proper relationship between
freedom and science in the pursuit of
truth
you can read more about it at our
website
this is the first of what we hope and
plan to be many lectures seminars and
conferences of the academy
uh which we'll host uh which will host
to combat the recent widespread abuses
of individual and academic freedom
made in the name of science
senior scholars at the academy or dr j
baracharya of stanford university
dr martin koldar formerly of harvard
medical school
and our speaker this evening dr scott
atlas
in addition to being a fellow at the
academy for science and freedom dr atlas
is also a senior fellow at the hoover
institution of stanford university
he has served as a senior advisor for
health care for several presidential
candidates and has advised congress on
health care reform
and from august to december 2020
he served as a special adviser to the
president united states and a member of
the white house corona virus task force
he is the author of a new book
a plague upon our house
my fight at the trump white house to
stop covet from destroying america
and tonight he is speaking on
the sarge to pandemic
appropriately subtitled
will truth prevail
dr scott atlas
[Applause]
okay thank you uh for that introduction
matt and thank everyone here for coming
and special thanks to dr arn and
hillsdale supporters for feeling that
this is a really critical time in our
period to stand up for freedom
and uh the deep politicization of
science
because without
science as a process
to determine truth
we we're going to be in trouble so uh
it's fantastic to work with hillsdale in
this endeavor as well as with my
colleagues uh jay bhattacharya and
martin koldorf and others and it's a
great honor to be the first speaker
in this new academy
so today i will talk about the pandemic
because the pandemic is not what the
academy is about but it is
it has exposed profound problems in our
society
uh that probably existed beforehand but
came to the fore
uh in bright colors
in frightening colors uh as we still see
today during the management of this
healthcare crisis
so uh
to understand
and set the scene for what problems we
face as a nation and what we hope to
address
expose and put forth solutions to
in this academy
i'll start by going through some of the
data
that uh is
free from the lens of politics
from censorship of the media
and free from censure of other
unenlightened universities that seem to
not understand their role in providing a
forum for the free exchange of ideas
now
if you could turn your heads to the
right we'll uh look at the slides and
i'm going to go through as i always did
in my career and as i always tried to do
in the task force i'm going to go
through the data
because we absolutely must live in a
country where facts matter and we are
seeing an overt denial of facts here
that at times can be frightening so to
understand what's going on we need to
know the facts and then we will lead
into i will go forward and talk about
what the results of the management were
of the pandemic where we are today
and how to move forward now this all
started back in early 2020 when the
world health organization came forward
and made several claims about this
so-called novel virus called the
sars2 virus
and those claims uh first and foremost
were that this was extremely lethal
and made the claims
that were absolutely incorrect to anyone
who had any experience looking at things
like fatality rates of diseases but they
took hold rapidly in the public and why
did they take hold because they were
joined in by computer modelers who
frankly were not
normally
in a position of a lot of influence in
the public and these models were based
on uh false assumptions
uh then the public health leaders uh
came forward and with their newfound
stardom
started amplifying this false data and
then that was really amplified by the
media and the social media as we know
so that the
really rapid ingraining of the public
was from the media and the social media
what was claimed
cyrus ii coronavirus has a far higher
fatality rate than the flu by several
orders of magnitude everyone has a
significant risk to die no one has
immunity because the virus is new hence
the end for novel
everyone is dangerous and spreads the
infection asymptomatic people are major
drivers of the spread
locking down which means closing schools
and businesses confining people to their
homes stopping non-coveted medical care
and eliminating travel and personal
movement will stop or eliminate the
virus
masks will protect everyone and stop the
spread and immune protection is only
from a vaccine and every one of these
claims is false is factually incorrect
every single one of these claims
the pandemic policy in the beginning
from the white house task force
was flatten the curve we all remember dr
deborah burks getting up on the podium
and trying to explain flatten the curve
which meant
reduce the rapidity of spread of the
virus
with a very logical rational reason and
that was so that hospitals would not be
overwhelmed so they can continue
medical care including for non-cova care
and secondarily flattening the curve
delaying the spread would allow for the
development of production of personal
protective equipment
sending beds where needed around the
country from the federal uh
from part of the federal solution uh
medical personnel availability for any
hospitals that would be overwhelmed and
hopefully delay so that some production
of drugs or vaccines would be initiated
the problem was that that and that that
curve by the way flattening the curve
never meant reducing the number of cases
never the same if you want to be a
mathematical person looking at a curve
the area under the curve didn't change
the number of cases was never supposed
to change with flatten the curve
the number of deaths was never going to
decrease would flatten the curve flatten
the curve was
specifically to stop hospitals from
being overcrowded
what happened sort of magically and
almost inexplicably was these same
public health leaders changed their
strategy
to instead of a very temporary two-week
flatten the curve stop covered 19 cases
at all costs
and so what happened was that dr
deborah burks who was the head of the
medical side of the task force the
so-called task force coordinator from
end of february 2020 on
and dr anthony fauci who was not the
head of anything except that he was the
most visible most influential task force
member
uh advised lockdown school closures
business restrictions and shutdowns
limits on medical care a host of other
personal mandates restrictions and
quarantine
and the result of that advice was that
the governors throughout the entire
country with rare exception
followed that advice in the spring of
2020 and throughout most of the year
and over 800 000 american deaths have
been attributed to the virus
millions of families so they did not
stop the deaths that strategy did not
stop the dust millions of families and
children were severely harmed from the
lockdowns particularly low-income
families and poor kids
from that policy from the lockdowns not
the violence
so to conclude if anyone has that
conclusion that the united states
federal pandemic policies failed that
u.s lives were lost with the wrong
policies
then one must conclude that the berks
vouchers restrictions and lockdowns
failed
because those were the restrictions that
were widely implemented during the
entire year of 2020 and beyond
that was to set the record straight on
something that's very important to
understand
because what we're seeing is an
orwellian attempt by lockdown advocates
to blame people who were opposed to what
was implemented for the failure of what
they advised and what was implemented
now the problem at the beginning of all
this without even talking about the
results of the lockdowns where the data
is severely flawed
these were things i brought up at the
task force by the way
no one else on the task force knew this
understood it or acknowledged it
pcr testing timelines and trends and
hospitalizations and deaths quote from
covet 19 are all problematic let's talk
about pcr testing this is still a
problem today
when you do pcr testing you have to do a
number of averages of the technique and
that's called cycle threshold basically
to detect a piece of virus that you want
to detect
at a cycle threshold of 35 which is the
value that we used to report
most
pcr tests in fact you can see that in
the united kingdom the nhs used a cycle
threshold of even higher 40 to 45. the
us used 35 to 40 and the fda recommended
40.
israel uses cycle threshold 37 this is
the number of averages used to detect
the
the virus
and the machine doesn't stop
until you detect the virus so if you're
using if it took 40 that meant it took
40 to detect the virus
it turns out that more than 97
of the positive tests using that
technique
are not detecting live contagious virus
they're detecting dead virus or
minuscule amounts people that are not a
threat
so the positive pcr test does not mean
you're contagious that's a problem
because you're confined you're
quarantined if you have a positive pcr
test
the second
surprise and i didn't know this until
later was that
somebody on the task force actually knew
this beside me his name was anthony
fauci in july 2020 he said at a cycle
threshold of 35 or more the chances of
it being replication competent meaning
contagious are minuscule in his words he
said you've got to say it's dead
nucleotides period irrelevant
a positive test
is not relevant if it's detecting
virus
the second big issue to talk about here
is we're starting to see a little bit of
discussion this admission of this now
but this is known
in the summer of 2020. i didn't get to
the white house until beginning of
august end of july 2020.
people that are hospitalized and
categorized as co-fort patients
are often
they're that categorization is used
because they have a positive sars test
they're not in the hospital for covet
they have in fact no symptoms of covid
whatsoever they're in the hospital for
something completely unrelated head
trauma broken leg appendicitis but once
they have a positive virus test they're
called covet hospitalization how often
does that occur this is a paper from
stanford's pediatric hospital from may
2021 that reviewed their own charts
and it turned out that about half of
patients had zero symptoms of covid but
were categorized as covet patients just
on the basis
of a virus test
this is a gross overestimate
of the danger therefore
of covid in children particularly
this is a study a larger study
of 163 coveted patients and children
86 of them
did not have coffin they were
categorized as co-foot they did not have
coveted 86 of hospitalized patients
the cdc actually admitted this in a
review that was published in april 2021
where they said that
the uh symptoms of reviewing the death
certificates
and hospitalizations in children
35 of them did not have any symptoms
that could in their words plausibly be
categorized as attributed to cova this
is death certificates
this is saying a third of people or more
who died from covid
in this cdc study over reviewing the
charts a third of patients who were
called covet deaths could not possibly
have had kovac
well this is what was known it was known
when i got the to the white house in the
late summer 2020 it has not changed it's
not new information it's not learned
information over the past year and a
half no matter what you hear
on cnn although i'm not sure anybody
here listens to cnn
the original world health organization
estimate was very high of infection
fatality rate that was actually orders
of magnitude higher than what it really
was it turns out that if you're under 70
the infection fatality is 0.05
under 70.
that's relatively close to what it is
from influenza
age is the most important risk factor
mean age for death was 80.
uh you know 99.2 percent of deaths are
people over 55.
eighty percent earned people uh over 65.
and so we we know that it's dangerous
for certain people very old people
but particularly people uh with
comorbidities one way to look at this is
the age risk
the risk of fatality is thousands fold
more
in old people than in children thousands
fold this is a very unique virus in that
way this is a blessing that it does not
impact significantly healthy children
it's different from the flu
in influenza in california
in the last influenza season that i
could get data on 5.4 of deaths and
influenza were in children
zero percent of deaths from coven are in
children in california that's not to say
zero deaths
but zero percent of deaths that's a
rounded number
for perspective on who dies from cova
the median age of people who die from
covet is equal to
or greater than
the life expectancy age in germany italy
the uk and the usa among other countries
that's not to minimize the tragedy of
people dying who are older but it's for
perspective which you never heard out of
the mouths of the people leading the
public health uh effort
i mentioned co-morbidities because age
is by far the most important risk factor
but a 75 year old marathon runner is not
at high risk for covid it's it's really
old people
who are very frail or other people who
are very frail by the way and what does
that mean that means you have underlying
conditions which now everybody uses the
word comorbidity it turns out that
two-thirds of people who died in the u.s
two-thirds of them had six or more
comorbidities
so if you had
hypertension high blood pressure treated
and no other
secondary uh no other underlying illness
that's not
a risk factor
to get a higher risk for death from
covet i had to explain this on the task
force uh it was either denied or they
didn't understand what i was talking
about i brought the scientific papers
with me unfortunately we had a you know
we didn't have very high level people on
the medical side of the task force
the risk to and from children is very
important because this is impacted
policy even today we have schools closed
and uh and children wearing mass and and
children thinking and learning that they
are a danger to others and that they are
a danger they are in danger themselves
here's the data from california
relatively recently as of a couple
months ago
although there were a lot of cases in
young people in california in ages 0-17
0 of deaths from covet in california
this is florida under 16
zero percent case fatality rate this is
florida under 30
zero percent
fatality rate from coving
if you're young and healthy you do
you're not in danger from coven period
we knew this
from all our studies all over the world
the risk to children
is extremely low if they're healthy
children if you have a serious
underlying illness as a child like
leukemia
or extreme obesity and other underlying
conditions that go with that okay you're
at high risk there's no question but
healthy children are not period
spread from children this was proven all
over the country this is not new
knowledge this was known in late spring
2020 from studies all over the world
norway sweden spain the netherlands
ireland england germany greece south
korea
israel
and iceland
children are
unusual to transmit
in fact pretty rare to transmit this
virus to adults
in fact
schools that are open are not a high
risk
setting they're a low risk setting in
fact if i could design a job where i
wanted to have low risk from covid i'd
want to be a school teacher
there is no special
material
vaccine policy testing policy
barriers distancing or anything else
that's needed in schools if you believe
in fact
in fact you know uh sweden opened up all
their schools during 2020 during the
height of the pandemic i'm not talking
about oma crime i'm
the wild type virus the regular virus
the first virus that was uh what was
part of stars ii
1.8 million children attended school
full-time no masks no distancing no
measures whatsoever
in sweden schools and no significant
problem from kovat were there some cases
of hospitalizations yes how many deaths
were there
zero healthy children have extremely low
risk of serious illness from covet and
almost no risk of death
children rarely spread the virus to
adults and there is absolutely no
special risk to teachers in school any
teacher
who says that there's certain conditions
that have to be met is making excuses
and does not have the interest of your
children in her
the case to open schools i made the case
at an event in the white house when i
first got there in early august
and that case is very simple healthy
children have do not have a significant
risk from this virus the harms of
closing in person schools are enormous
to children
and there is absolutely nothing more
important to a civilized society than
educating its children
the second part of this stuff is
the harms of the closures that is never
spoken about
online learning is a failure and it is
not just because people don't have
computers
in the country in the world with the
most widespread broadband access and
computers the netherlands they had
severe drops in learning in children
particularly in certain uh classes of
families meaning less educated parents
for instance again highlighting that the
lockdowns were a luxury of the rich the
affluence had no significant problem
with the lockdowns but the people that
those same
elite class pretend to care about
working class lower income families they
were destroyed by the lockdowns and
their children were specifically harmed
from the school closures
in virginia
nearby here of course this was early
data from
i think summer of
2020 that had already been compiled
massive explosion of failing grades up
83
reading and math losses 30 to 50 just
after the spring 2020 closure these
closures went on for for months and even
the full year in most of the country a
stanford study said the findings on
learning losses are chilling that was
the first sentence of their conclusion
again all of these losses were far
greater for minorities in the poor and
there were other losses that people
presumably in this room don't really
think about a lot of kids
that's the first place they get hearing
or vision problems detected because they
don't have a family doctor necessarily
they have nutritional needs met
all of our children go to school to
learn conflict resolution group
interactions physical activity you can
learn a lot online but you can't learn
socialization
what about more serious heart
this is compared year to year
the 2020 lockdown year versus the
previous year
closing in-person schools
and mental health and teenagers is the
title of the slide but what this slide
shows is there was a significant drop
in all medical claims to doctors all
medical visits by teenagers because
medical care was disrupted significantly
but there was an explosion of mental
health claims this is actual insurance
claim data comparing year to year 2020
to the previous year of 2019. that's
mental health claims what about this
slide this is a tripling of self-harm
visits year to year by teenagers during
the lockdown because of the isolation
these are what do we mean self-harm we
mean children putting cigarettes out on
their skin
slashing their wrists and i'm being
graphic intentionally here because these
are real people that were impacted this
is not about stopping of respiratory
virus that by the way children have no
significant risk from if they're healthy
this is generalized anxiety disorder
major depressive disorder and adjustment
disorder an explosion in college-aged
children
harms to the younger generation due to
the lockdown the isolation
this is explosion of overdoses substance
use
by teenagers this is all teenager year
to year data 2020 lockdown year versus
2019.
and there are many many other things i
could quote i won't go through the whole
slide but just to cite that in a july
cdc study from 2020 they said
that three-fourths of college-aged
children in the united states reported
at least one mental health system
symptom by june 2020
and there was
one in four of our college-age children
thought of killing himself in june of
2020 because of that first spring
lockdown
mandela said there can be no keener
revelation of a society's soul than the
way in which it treats his children
the way the united states has treated
his children is a disgrace and i'm
saying that specifically because this
country is an outlier
we are the only country among our peer
nations that close schools
in the fall of 2020. all the european
countries almost without exception
knew the data and they opened their
schools we didn't something like 17 of
kids in the us had in-person instruction
now lockdown is very important because
it's a dirty word now and the people who
are the lockdown advocates know it's a
dirty word so they try to run away from
their own policy
lockdown means closing schools and
businesses limiting medical care for
non-covet illnesses limiting personal
interactions including seeing your own
grandparents or grandchildren
restricting personal movement travel
curfews and quarantining low-risk
asymptomatic people that's locked down
what did the lockdowns do they failed
why do i say that well this is bjorn
study march 2021 on the left
looking at the data in mortality from 24
european countries the more severe
lockdown policies did not reduce
death from kovac
this is bhattacharya ben david o and
ian's january 2021 first authors ben
david
they looked at the spread restrictive
lockdowns did not reduce the growth of
cases in fact johnny andes was quoted as
saying the lockdowns in many cases were
pro contagion because remember the
lockdowns can find people indoors
this is completely antithetical to
simple common sense for a virus that's
spread indoors
and the most striking study of all that
i recommend everyone look at who wants
to be informed from data is the study
from rand institute in june 2021
that said that the analyzed lockdown
policies in 43 countries and in all the
u.s states
and what they found was that with longer
shelter-in-place orders there was an
increase in excess death access deaths
are that's beyond baseline of a
non-pandemic here
so
longer in shelter-in-place orders longer
lockdowns more access does faster
lockdowns earlier onset
more excess deaths in the 43 countries
with available data the excess deaths
were falling before the lockdowns but
once the lockdowns were instituted the
excess deaths began increasing at the
time of the lockdowns and that was also
true in the united states where deaths
increased once the lockdowns were
implemented
the false dichotomy was set up
to make people believe
that lock guns were the only way to go
now what do i mean by that well this is
back in the spring of 2020
where i wrote a paper because i wondered
where were the economists the economist
knew from decades of literature that a
severe economic shutdown will kill
people
yet the false dichotomy was set up by
the lockdown advocates that people that
were against the lockdowns were choosing
money economy over life but it really
was a lie it was a false statement it
was lives versus life we did a study i
did this because i was called up by one
of the university of chicago economist
uh john burge we did this uh together
with ralph keaney from duke and
alexander lipton
uh who was from uh
university of jerusalem
and we quantified that the loss of life
years by may of 2020
was double from the lockdown than from
the virus
why would that happen because medical
care was shut down first of all okay we
might not remember it but half of a 650
000 u.s cancer patient population
skipped their chemotherapy they were
afraid to come into a hospital
40 of stroke patients half of heart
attack patients did not call an
ambulance they were afraid to come into
a hospital
organ transplants from living donors
were down 85
from the previous year
these medical illnesses did not go away
everybody understands that of course but
you don't you don't think about it
more than two-thirds of cancer
screenings were skipped
what do you think is going to happen to
these people
the cancers didn't go away they're going
to come back with widespread disease
what's called metastatic disease which
is
severe
pain severe suffering and many of them
will die
because they skip their cancer
screenings and their chemotherapy if
they had a cancer
severe child abuse cases brought to the
emergency room skyrocketed
it wasn't bad enough
that two to three hundred thousand child
abuse cases were not reported in the
spring of 2020 alone in the u.s because
the schools were closed the schools are
the number one agency to notice child
abuse
but
massive increases in the cases that were
brought to the emergency room now what
does that mean okay i've been a doctor
where i've had to come in the middle of
the night and look at a head ct scan and
tell the police is standing there
this baby cannot go home with these
people this is child abuse
and so
when you're used to that
and you know what happens with people
the people that bring their child into
the emergency room
who beat the child they think they
killed the child these are the most
severe cases skyrocketed by 35 i was
getting emails from emergency room
doctors all over the country including
in michigan by the way speaking of
hillsdale
telling me what was going on in their
emergency rooms
during the first two months of the
pandemic two months more than one-third
of u.s excess deaths were not due to
covet those were lockdown desks the
lockdowns literally killed people
the lockdowns as i say are the luxury of
the rich why is that because not only
were people able to
order in their food have people from
amazon come in and deliver their stuff
get together with their neighbors in the
neighborhoods like where i live in palo
alto where everybody's got a phd and you
can have a little home school
regular people don't have that but even
worse this is national data unemployment
low wage jobs during the first
year or so of the lockdown dropped by
23.6
high rates high wage jobs increased
by 2.4
the lockdowns of the united states
inflicted worldwide harms
we don't think about this stuff but when
you look at the numbers it's staggering
and what i mean by the lockdowns are the
lockdowns and the advice of the faces of
public health leadership of the us
because these people are listened to
all over the world
everybody in the world knows who dr
fauci is the public health leaders of
these other countries they're influenced
by the public health leaders of the
united states
we are an interconnected world obviously
economically there's there's no way to
disentangle what happens in a poor
country
when the u.s shuts down
that's where they get their income
and so we look at things like
interruption of medical care and the
supply chain
to these poorer countries this year
alone there will be 400 000 new deaths
from tuberculosis alone
tens of thousands of additional malaria
doesn't babies occurred in 2020 because
they couldn't get the resources they
couldn't get the malaria nuts everything
was locked down the medications were
disrupted
one and a half billion children were
shut out of education a hundred million
more children this is unicef projection
or were and uh other international
organizations
a hundred million more children will
suffer sexual abuse and exploitation
violence genital mutilation and
childhood pregnancies because of the
lockdown
when poverty occurs because of economic
shutdown in a poor country
life expectancy falls not everywhere in
the world is the united states when you
have countries in africa
southeast asia thrown into abject
poverty 97 million more people in 2020
alone
were thrown into extreme poverty what
does that mean that means they get less
than 1.90 a day to live liver
okay so uh in places like bangladesh is
one example
their whole
gdp really depends on almost almost
depends on one industry garment
manufacturing for the western nations
you shut down the u.s and western europe
you've wiped up
the total income for 4.1 million
families
in bangladesh
this is the analysis of the impact of
the lockdown on a global basis that was
published in the uh summer of 2021
analyzing 124 countries and it showed
number one the countries with the
biggest reductions in mobility meaning
the lockdowns were associated with the
biggest losses of life
and 1.2 billion life years were lost due
to the lockdowns 25 times as many life
years as was lost due to covet
the lockdowns failed to protect the
elderly they failed to stop the spread
of the virus they killed people and
destroyed families and sacrificed
children especially low-income and the
poor while sparing the affluent that's
the science for people who want to quote
the sign
now the alternative always existed
i said it after johnny and edie said it
from stanford in late february early
march
and then several other people said it
sinatra gupta of oxford jay bhattacharya
and martin kaldorf my colleagues in this
hillsdale initiative
and several other people
the alternative was focused or targeted
protection
this was not even complicated this is
simple common sense we knew who was at
high risk
we knew who wasn't at high risk
let's protect the people at high risk
and not destroy the people at low risk
yet that wasn't done and what that means
is increasing the protection of the high
risk group
monitoring hospitals and sending
supplies and opening schools medical
care businesses and transportation
for the low-risk people and the people
who want to go and live their lives
now this was called
dangerous this was the second lie
perpetrated by the lockdown advocates
the first was you're choosing money over
life the second was anyone who's against
the lockdowns is dangerous because
you're advocating something that they
deemed what's called herd immunity
strategy which of course i was accused
of many times in the press
i never said that of course because what
that means
to these people
was letting the virus spread survival of
the fittest let it go and whoever
survived survives will build up
population community that's not what i
recommended that's not what anybody
recommended that i knew that was never
said in the white house never said to
the president united states i never even
heard anyone talk like that what we said
was increase the protection with
specific measures of the people who were
dying from the current lockdown policy
the berks fauci policy was not
protecting the older high-risk people
finally in october
uh the something called the great
barrington declaration was written
co-authored by again two of my
colleagues here uh dr koldorf and dr
bhattacharya and sinatra gupta uh these
people are all at the top level of
epidemiology medical science vaccine
scientists at some of the what we used
to think of as elite universities i'm
not so sure i buy into that anymore
but um this was claimed as fringe
in fact we've seen the emails recently
by between the head of the nih francis
collins and dr fauci
uh
um
instigating
media attack on this on these authors
calling them fringe and using their
power
to get what they called a quote take
down
of these scientists
okay this is you know as far as i know
unprecedented it's a shameful way to end
their careers and i'm happy this is
being recorded because i want that
statement on record
it was also said
when uh i was saying that i believe in
the core principles of the great
barrington declaration that was
increasing protection for the people at
high risk and stopping the damage of the
lockdowns that's the gist of the great
barrington declaration
president biden as candidate went on 60
minutes and said no one agrees with dr
atlas no credible doctor and i say well
when i look at a statement here that's
signed by 15 000
medical scientists and 44 000 medical
practitioners and about a million people
that's a lot of nobodies that's my
answer to that criticism now it turns
out that it wasn't just that the
lockdowns failed to stop the infection
to stop the death and inflicted
we
damage
an internal control like we say in in a
medical experiment
and that is we have a state that didn't
do the lockdowns that instead tried to
do targeted protection that state is
florida
after the initial shutdowns governor uh
desantis decided to open all schools at
the end of august 2020 to not have
mandated uh business closures
and what do we see from the results
okay well after one full year
of that
florida outperformed the average u.s and
deaths per capita from coveted florida
outperformed 25 states remember the
other states did the lockdowns the
burden is not on florida to outperform
the other states the burden is on the
states that imposed collateral damage
to save lives compared to florida
florida doesn't have to do better
because they didn't destroy people's
lives they didn't kill people with the
lockdowns
the excess mortality incredible increase
after a year florida outperformed by 24
percent the average in the us and
outperformed two-thirds of the states
age-adjusted covert mortality which is
important because as you know this is a
disease that really impacts old people
and spares young people generally and
florida has a lot of old people
and so we look at the age-adjusted covet
mortality after one year florida
outperformed by 40 percent the average
in the us they outperformed 40 states
and they outperformed 40 states for
people 65 and over outperformed
because of targeted protection
now let's compare florida and california
where i live because they're sort of
similar california and florida are very
large diverse
states
mixed urban rural
relatively similar weather although i
strongly prefer california weather to
florida
uh but um the key differences were
florida's the fifth oldest state in the
country this is a disease that kills old
people selectively basically california
is the seventh youngest state in the
country so right away we're saying okay
california has an advantage here to
begin with for this disease
secondly the comparison which i'm
getting at is that florida was open
widely since late summer 2020
california's had one of the longest most
stringent lockdown policies
what do we see well in the top graph on
the right that's florida green as
schools were open since fall 2020.
and the bottom we see green as what
schools are open in california again
less than 20 percent of students for a
year
had in-person schools in california
what about protecting people from dying
this is after one year age-adjusted
covert mortality rate
worse in california than florida
access mortality increased worse in
california than florida that's after one
year
now what happened is the media and
normal people i guess and i don't
consider the media normal people
um like to take a point in time and say
aha okay now look at florida okay so
they did that at the
late summer 2021 when there was a surge
of cases in the south on that graph you
can see that yellow and bright toward
the white is increased cases whereas the
rest of the country's pretty dark
meaning not a lot of cases that was the
surge in the late summer 2021
and they said wow look what happened
well i wrote in the preface of my book
the forward of my book that and i was
writing it at the time i said what's
going to happen of course is that the
cases are going to go down in florida
and then go up in the rest of the
country because how did i know that
which is exactly what happened on the
october third map very few cases in the
south in florida the rest of the country
was basically exploding how did i know
that because
that's what happened last year identical
last year meaning the year before this
is july 2020 cases in the south texas
florida not much elsewhere and then in
the fall
exploding in the rest of the country and
very few so you have to be careful when
you're making the comparison so i gave
you the comparison after one year now
i'm giving you the comparison after the
entire pandemic relatively to date here
this is january 7th
access mortality during the whole
pandemic california did worse than
florida no matter what you hear from the
politicians in california they either
don't know the data or they're lying
those are the only two options
this is age-adjusted coveted mortality
by state this is at the end of the year
2021 and we see that florida
outperformed more than half the states
roughly
uh
60 of the states and it's about the same
as californian age-adjusted mortality
this preacher evolves of course because
this doesn't include some deaths but
we'll see what happens but basically
again the burden is on the other states
not on florida to prove they did better
let's talk about the vaccines this is a
topic that everybody wants to hear about
this is the data on the vaccines i'm not
going to give you any of the opinion i'm
going to show you the graphs from the
studies
and then we'll talk about what they show
this is data from israel
that showed that the vaccines
back
analyzed in mid after summer 2021
the vaccines were very good for stopping
people from getting severe disease or
dying
roughly 90 effective that's that's very
good
and not very good at stopping you from
getting another infection 39 effective
after
only
roughly six months five five months
this is their data uh on symptomatic
infection regular any infection
symptomatic infection hospitalization
and severe
covet or death
hospitalization or severe covid again 90
for the duration of the study
the problem with not
understanding that and claiming
uh on one hand that the vaccines don't
work
is you're undermining
the confidence people should have in the
value of the vaccines the vaccines
prevent people from dying
and i'm going to show you more data on
this this is a study from qatar october
2021. why would i look at qatar by the
way you'd think oh why would i trust
qatar well first of all i don't trust
the data coming out of the cdc and so
i'm forced to look at other countries
second of all qatar actually they
vaccinated almost our entire population
they were very rigid about it so it
provides a good sort of experimental
setting and they looked at protection
against death hospitalization and
infection and here's what they show
and what i'm going to show you here is
that after four months
there's only about a 20
effectiveness of getting another against
getting another virus infection so after
four months the protection against
getting an infection
from the with vaccine
uh is is minimal it disappears
this is the protection
again of vaccinated people against
getting severe
critical fatal cases of covet very high
down here you can't comment because this
error bar means there's very few cases
so through the duration of the study
you're talking 85 90 effectiveness
against death and severe disease that's
very good
this is a study from sweden
this is the effectiveness of the
vaccination against the risks as i
talked about of up to nine months
the vaccine effectiveness against
getting coveted meaning a set of
symptoms due to the sars virus dropped
significantly
in all comers
after about
four months like qatar's data
what about against hospitalization or
death after about nine months it still
it drops when you take all comers but i
looked at their data and made a new
graph from their data this is their data
it's not in the paper
and it shows that people that are under
80 years old
the protection against death is very
high
this is sweden the protection drops
against death in people who are over 80
after about six months
to about 50
so there is a waning of protection from
of the vaccine against dying
but not for people under 80. this is the
data we know so far remember this is a
new vaccine we don't we haven't had this
for years
here's the study the follow-up study on
comparing
those who've had the infection
versus those who've been vaccinated but
never had the infection
this is the israel study from late
summer
people who have recovered from covet but
never been vaccinated
have a 27 fold fewer
cases than people who've been vaccinated
but never had covert
okay this is the point that you get
coveted
you get natural what people call natural
immunity this is not news by the way it
would have been a shock if this wasn't
true this is biology that you learn in
high school if you're taking ap biology
every single competent doctor
should know this this is expected this
is proven in other viruses and it is
also proven in this virus
people who have recovered from covet but
never been vaccinated have a 13 fold
decrease incidence
of any infection
compared to people who've been
vaccinated and never had coven and
people who've had covenant recovered
but never vaccinated have an eightfold
decrease in incidence of
covart that requires hospitalization
compared to people who've been
vaccinated but never infected the
protection of having had coveted
without vaccination
is better than the protection of having
had vaccination without covert that's
fact
it turns out that they also looked at
the people who've been vaccinated
who've been recovered from the infection
but never vaccinated
versus recovered and then vaccinated
just in case
and they looked at what happened with
these two groups
against symptomatic infection no
difference
against
all infection no difference there's no
difference in the israel data between
people who've been recovered from covet
and never vaccinated and recovered from
covet and then vaccinated no difference
no benefit to the vaccine and people
recovered from covert that's what that
israel studies show the follow-up study
from israel december
2021
they had three categories of people
recovered
but never vaccinated recovered then
vaccinated
or vaccinated then recovered
and then what happened later
all three categories had equivalent
protection against another sars
infection that means people who've been
recovered from the infection
with or without a vaccine have the same
protection that's the israel data
all three groups anyone who's recovered
with or without a vaccine
has far fewer new infections than people
who've been double vaccinated
but never infected
that's a fact
protection against severe covet because
that's really what counts if you think
about it
recovered people recovered then
vaccinated vaccinated and recovered have
the exact equivalent protection against
severe covenant that means people who've
had the virus and recovered compared to
people who've been vaccinated and also
had the virus no benefit
in that study to being vaccinated
for people who've had the virus
people who've been vaccinated have
afford a tenfold higher rate of severe
covet
than people who've recovered from cove
at once
even if they've never been vaccinated
this is a graph of that this is the
easier slide i should have shown first
this is time left to right
the blue is p light blue are people that
have been vaccinated but never had
coveted what is the incidence
of getting infected
it's increasing over time
these
curves are people who've been
vaccinated then recovered
alone
never vaccinated
and that and recovered and then
vaccinated they're all the same
over time and much lower than the people
who've been vaccinated but never
infected in terms of
new infections
that's not opinion
this is newer data on omicron
this is denmark
december 20th study
time since vaccine
pfizers and modernism protection against
omicron
okay
after two months
the protection against omicron in fully
vaccinated people
is between four and nine percent
okay that's that's nearly zero
right in two months
if you're getting vaccines repeatedly to
stop you from getting the infections
like omicron and it takes two weeks to
generate antibodies to the vaccine
you're gonna have to get an injection
every month
every single month
forever this is something i didn't
highlight but at the bottom of the slide
this is their data on the booster
protection against omicron at the peak
of its protection
meaning at the end of one month
54
only stoppage of new infections
at the peak of the boosters protection
against homicide
that's just the same size so here's the
summary
covet vaccines protect against death and
severe disease and that's very important
to understand for the people who keep
insisting the vaccines don't work i
don't agree with that statement that's
not what the data shows the vaccines
protect against severe disease and death
and if you're high risk for that
there's a case to be made you should
take the vaccine
vaccines protect against infection but
that protection is very temporary it
drops to very low after only four months
and nearly zero against omicron after
only two months
so
it's personally protective
in terms of stopping you from dying
but it does not stop you from getting an
infection in a few months and therefore
in spreading an infection so another way
to look at it is it's a private
protective measure but it is not
protecting people who you think are a
danger to it's not stopping the spread
there's no public benefit
to having vaccines of other people
you're worried you're high risk get the
vaccine
you're not stopping the spread of the
infection from other people by forcing
them to get the vaccine
vaccines do not protect against
infection or symptomatic infection as
well as the immunity of recovered
patients that's factually true and that
was acknowledged this week maybe two
days ago by the cdc finally
there are safety concerns about the
vaccines the biggest problem of all is
simply we don't have the data there's
been a a really harmful lack of
transparency
about the safety
data on the vaccines remember
most vaccines don't give us all the
safety data until five years
we have a vaccine here that was done
very quickly
in a health emergency
but you can't even assess the safety of
a vaccine this quickly but we have not
had even full transparency about the
side effects and we know that young
males particularly but not only
have a certain risk of myocarditis from
the vaccine remember they don't have a
significant risk if they're healthy from
the disease
so in my book
you're having a situation where you're
injecting healthy children with a
vaccine for a disease they don't have
significant risk for
what about covet vaccines and children
this is a quote a shameful quote from
the editor-in-chief of the new england
journal eric rubin october 26th quote
but we're never going to learn about how
safe this vaccine is unless we start
giving it that's just the way it goes
i never thought that would be said in
the united states of america
this is a quote from another country
because
i said we were an outlier with closing
schools we're an outlier with the
vaccines for children we keep pushing
vaccines for children in our schools and
elsewhere healthy children
the uk's advisory committee said the
margin of benefit based primarily on a
health perspective is too small to
support advice on a universal program of
vaccination of otherwise healthy 12 to
15 year olds
where is the
moral and ethical concerns
of our u.s public health leaders
america's media has contributed to the
frenzy in the united states
and it's been uniquely harmful this is a
study
comparing this is i think november 2020
comparing the english-speaking media
in the us
versus elsewhere
negative coveted stories u.s major media
91 quantifiably negative
non-us english language media only 54
negative we had the same pandemics as
western europe had
the u.s media
stories of increasing cases outnumbered
the stories of decreasing cases in 2020
by a factor of five
even when the cases were declining
there was a distortion of what was going
on by the united states media including
about schools what is the legacy of that
the legacy
is a damaged
public particularly younger generation i
talked about the the the
psychological impacts that were
horrendous
what about just simply softer things
like fear
okay this is in in the summer of 2020.
this is in purple
the share of respondents worried that it
was serious health effects coming to
their generation compared to the reality
the younger generations were grossly
exaggerating by factors of 100 or more
how dangerous the virus was to them
whereas people that were over 65
they had a rational
assessment of what was going on and they
were the only ones really at risk
in fact there's a survey done on uh
spring of 2021
and we notice here that people in
college asian united states half of them
said they were nervous about any social
interaction again i mean that that's
striking to me that is really tragic
you know public health is more than just
stopping this virus
during the lockdown
americans gained a lot of weight but
what i'm pointing out here is that
college age generation
52 of them had an unwanted weight gain
during the 2020 lockdown and that weight
gain averaged 28 pounds
that's a that's obesity that's a public
health problem that's not a cosmetic
extra five pounds
i mean it's really incredible now all of
this
is getting to the point of the talk
which is
why we're so uh
focused on this in this hillsdale
initiative of the academy for science
and freedom
because we have lost trust rightfully so
in institutions that we need to trust
one of course is media and social media
another is science public health
agencies scientific journals
teachers and education leaders
and academia in general why have we lost
us because they've given erratic advice
often directly contrary to the evidence
they've falsely declared consensus in
scientific journals on things that were
simply false let alone no consensus and
by the way you don't declare what
science has shown by saying we are in
consensus here that's not how it works
there's been a gross politicization of
science the scientific journals
including the best journals in the world
lancet new england journal british
medical journal jama
have been
publishing
diatribes against people who just simply
disagreed with the interpretation of the
data that they wanted to hear
instead of criticizing the data they've
been character smears that's
politicization of science
there's been intimidation and censure on
university campuses which is
reprehensible destructive to the free
exchange of ideas that universities are
supposed to stand for and dangerous
because these are the people in charge
of educating our children the nation's
future leaders
there's been overt censorship in the
media
they've pulled down youtube
videos not just of me of many people uh
governor desantis had a panel on the
pandemic management early in uh 20
uh 2021
he asked me dr bhattacharya called
orphan gupta to participate in this
panel open to the press we had q a
youtube pulled it down and said it was
misinformation it's the governor of
florida
uh and for
you know pretty credentialed uh
researchers on the pandemic
and luckily we had a governor in florida
who called me up the next day and said
we're going to do another panel on the
pull down by youtube
so you can't be afraid you have to
continue thank god for people that
understand that
now i want to talk specifically about
what's happening on university campuses
because hillsdale is a university campus
and hillsdale doesn't do this and this
is a direct contrast to why we need
university leaders who understand that
this kind of behavior that i'm going to
point out is unacceptable to a
university
there's this this is sort of a story of
three stanford university medical
scientists johnny andes myself and jay
bhattacharya
and
we all said the identical things about
who's at risk about the risk to children
about immunity from the infection about
the ineffectiveness of masks about how
schools should open
about the harms of lockdowns and about
the way to do this was focus protection
and not only do i know we said the same
things i often said exactly what they
said i was talking to them almost every
day for almost the whole year
yet only one of us
was issued an official rebuke from
faculty members in the stanford
university uh faculty senate i wonder
why
okay and the why is because
i had the audacity to think that i
should help the country
under a president that the stanford
university faculty doesn't like
and why do i say that that's so
political
it's not just i'm i'm thinking this this
is the voting record of stanford zip
code where i happen to live and compared
to california that by the trump vote in
the state of california was two to one
in stanford zip code which you have to
be a faculty member basically or
high-level staff to live
ninety-five percent by three percent
trump
the problem right now is that the free
exchange of ideas that are obviously
fundamental
not just to this country to all free
societies is under threat
and without the united states having
freedom of speech i don't think that any
other country is going to end up with
freedom like this
so what are we doing about it well this
is what we're doing about it here
uh dr earn and the supporters of
hillsdale and the people
that comprise hillsdale are committed
to fixing the problem
with at least science
and because without freedom in science
you don't have science there is no such
thing as science without the free
exchange the interpretations
uh the the debate that's how you win the
argument
if you're not capable of doing that you
don't even belong at the table but
science is not done by decree
and so uh
myself uh
dr koldorf and dr bhattacharya were here
in this room
uh on december 10th announcing this new
academy which we will operate
uh mainly out of the dc campus
but we will be uh the purpose really is
to first educate the american people
about what is happening here
because it's shocking to me how often i
give a talk like this
and so many people come up and say
they've never heard any of this okay
because of this was not allowed to be
presented
and it's pretend to think we're learning
this stuff now the harms and lockdowns
were done while we knew everything i
showed you here except for the stuff
about the vaccine
effectiveness
and we have a continuation of today so
we're going to educate the american
people
uh hopefully with the help of press who
are interested in making this visible
and uh
we're going to try to explore solutions
and so this is the first event of many
we're going to have lectures like this
seminars group discussions panels some
of which involve the media some of which
involve students
mainly in dc but also in other campuses
of
of hillsdale and we hope that people
here that support freedom
uh
are going to support this initiative
i'll finish with a couple of quick
slides here this is i gave a talk at the
university of milan law school
about a month ago on coven
where okay this is a country that has
been
hurt very much italy uh by covid uh but
as opposed to what i see in the
universities in the united states they
asked me to give a talk at the
university
and they we went out to dinner and they
were they were in they were very
interested
in the data that i was presenting it was
very civilized
and i think the us has lost a lot of
that humanity frankly
but this is a slide that i showed in
milan because it's the main newspaper
of italy corriere la delicera in 1992
which after
359 years the catholic church admitted
that the earth moved that galileo was
right and i'm betting that the
lockdowners are going to take longer
than 359 years
so to finish a quote that i think dr
aaron appreciates because he's a winston
churchill scholar
truth is incontrovertible panic may
resent it ignorance may deride it malice
may distort it but there it is thank you
very much
thank you so we have some time um for
questions and i i think this is
important to ask questions because uh
everybody has questions about what
they've heard what they've seen and we
have roving microphones
and so we're gonna
start out with the back of the room
uh hi there my name is philip wegman no
one pays me for my opinion but i'm a
journalist and i would like to know that
um
during our interview because that was
remarkable at the time
my question though is
i remember in march of 2020 trump said
in the briefing room that the cure could
not be worse than the disease and the
after action report that you've
presented here has been very helpful
but as you noted
a lot of what you've presented except
for the vaccines was known at the time
so
as you look back what was the
i guess blockage in the supply chain
that stopped
uh warning about lockdowns from getting
to the president who is the decision
making
yeah i mean it's you know when i go
through i wrote a book the play a plague
upon our house to document
the history of what actually happened
there is nobody else that will give you
the honest view of what happened inside
that task force room during the four
months that i was there
and advising the president and to set
the historical record and to try to
answer some of these very questions
what i saw
so i didn't get there till the end of
july beginning of august
and uh dr burks was in charge of the
task force from the end of february 2020
onward so for six months
the task force
was focused on locking down closing up
everything restricting medical care etc
but the president was on record several
times as you just mentioned
saying wait a second
common sense uh
we're going to destroy children
by having schools closed we're going to
destroy society by shutting all
businesses
and
this virus only really is is severely
dangerous to certain people why don't we
protect them
he said this in his common-sense way
several times
um
the difference was when i got there i i
knew all the data about it and uh had
been saying this independently of course
for for us for five six months
but dr burks
and dr fauci were delegated
the authority
okay they they from my understanding
they went to the president they
convinced him that 15 days
short period of time we're going to do a
shutdown
and i think that's a persuasive argument
i think for any of us if we would have
thought 15 days
to shut down that in the end will be a
blip people can handle 15 days even
though it will be somewhat harmful
but then it evolved into this frenzy
this obsession with stopping all cases
of covid which was
irrational
uh and just simply against all biology
of what we knew about respiratory
viruses
and my my um my experience there was uh
if you're asking me
why did that why was that message
allowed okay the way it was set up was
the white house task force which was run
by dr burke's on the medical side and
the logistics side was separate the
logistical side was sort of operational
and that was running pretty well
although they stumbled very badly early
on with testing before i got there
uh but uh the medical side was mainly dr
berks who was the task force coordinator
dr fauci who was the public face of it
all
uh and dr redfield the head of the cdc
and what i saw
were people who uh when i was asked a
question about an issue like what's the
risk to children in schools
i came prepared with a dozen or 20
scientific articles from the world's
publication the data i went through a
critique of the studies that weren't
very good if the design was poor the
conclusion was invalid etc
i was met i never saw once
any of the three of them bring in a
scientific paper i never saw once any of
them refute what i said with scientific
data i never saw them disagree with each
other once in any of the meetings that i
came to and what that means that's a red
flag scientists are known to disagree
with each other
um
and all i was met with was the
accusation that i was an outlier or
fringe
and so this is not the behavior of
scientists this is the behavior of
government bureaucrats the policy was
delegated to people who were in
government bureaucrat positions for 35
and 40 years
the way people survive in government
bureaucrat positions now this is my
opinion
is not because they're politically
neutral but because they're politically
savvy they know how to navigate a highly
politicized environment they have
friends
in your profession in the media uh they
have friends uh in the agencies and it
turned out
these three
was revealed by dr uh burks after i left
they had a pact
fauci burton redfield they were all
going to quit
if one of them got fired by president
trump does that impress you as people
interested in helping stopping people
from dying
and helping the country
okay i'll let you make the conclusion
the other thing that was very striking
to me was not only the non-scientific
complete lack of critical thinking there
was this bizarre very uh sophomoric
really tabulation of cases that they
were showing that you could download
from any public website that's not
analysis
okay they were saying correlation of two
things happening meant causation you
know if i uh
if i get up early that day and it's
sunny
did i cause the sun to come out or did
it just happen at the same time
this is the level of the thinking there
and i'm not exaggerating it happened
with the masked issue uh but then the
other difference that i saw was these
people
were not were interested
uh in
not we're not interested in having the
scientific debate at all
i brought in
experts in virus uh science in vaccines
in pediatric infectious disease from
coast to coast to meet with the
president
why because i was an advisor i wanted
him to get the information i want him to
have his questions answered by the
people doing the research on the
pandemic from ucla
tufts medical center harvard and
stanford we set that meeting up so dr
burke specifically could attempt i wrote
about this in the book so
it's public but
she refused to come she canceled right
before the meeting the day before not
because she had a conflict she didn't
want to come
this is not the behavior
of somebody who is a scientist
you want to speak to the people doing
the research you want to bounce your
ideas off of them you want to hear what
they have to say
if you're not
[Music]
confident enough
that you can
discuss differences with other expert
scientists you don't belong in the room
first of all but second of all uh
it's just frightening who was in charge
of the policy and the
if there is a a problem with the way it
was done
uh i believe that there were some
political uh concerns with people
advising the president
who said and they told me i'm saying
this because they told me
the quote that i kept hearing was don't
rock the boat scott don't rock the boat
and i kept saying
the boat is frigging capsized okay
people are dying
the place was out of control the
country's off the rails the boats
capsized
okay i'm not worried about rocking the
boat
but there was a political issue
a concern
and it was very difficult when you had
people are heavily credentialed
we have people like dr fauci
uh and dr burks give an adulation in the
media
propped up on a pedestal have scientific
credentials and we're talking to people
who have no medical knowledge whatsoever
in the white house it's difficult to go
against that even though
the president did speak against that
because he knew the policy was wrong and
it was failing and it was dangerous
and so uh it's a very difficult
environment washington dc it's political
uh inherently
uh and it was uh very difficult to
navigate for somebody who was basically
like me and neophyte i didn't know what
was going on in the beginning frankly uh
but um we see from the exposure of the
emails and the email troves that these
people were politicized people they were
political they were trying to smear
other people instead of spending their
time doing the drug trials that should
have been done doing the debates
uh and interested in other opinions so
the bottom line was long-winded answer
the policies were
taken over
by bureaucrats that should have never
been in charge of this policy
yes
can you wait for the microphone
thank you
day after day
day after day hour after hour we saw dr
fauci
and we saw dr burks behind him
and it occurred to me from a pr point of
view
that an economist should have equal time
maybe a stephen moore munchen whomever
from a think tank from a uh university
research university
did the task force ever even once
approach president trump and say to the
american people that are experiencing
this bad economy the economy that's
sinking
we think from a pr point of view it
would be good
to balance faucet with some kind of
economist did that ever get played
there were economists involved in the
task force in the room in the task force
meetings
um
and they pointed out everything but the
message to the public
was simply
stopping covet 19 cases that was the
visible messenger dr fauci and dr burke
so remember dr burks by the way as task
force coordinator gave all of the
writing
and written medical advice
to the states all of it she wrote it to
the governors every one of them she
visited dozens of states with or without
the vice president i visited one state
by the way during my time there florida
i didn't visit any other state so the
task force official federal guideline
was dr burke's
the
visible face on tv and in the media was
dr fauci
they never voiced
never not once in my presence anything
about the harms of the lockdowns never
yes
hi uh thanks first of all for for a very
informative talk and thanks for all that
you've done thus far my question has to
do with actual treatment uh
non-hospitalization type treatment
um
that
tell me if i'm wrong but i think i'm
right and that there's virtually no
prescribed protocol for treating kovid
other than
if you get really sick go to the
hospital
um
there appear to be some drugs out there
that are at least to some degree
effective in at least in a prophylactic
sense early in the stages of the disease
but
there's no official policy by any
medical school or certainly government
agencies i think that's correct and and
if it is then why why do you think it is
that yeah well the way first of all the
way medicine is practiced is generally
um
not so rigidly number one in general
it's not necessarily true that there's
an official way to treat something but
there are standard ways to treat
diseases you're pointing out something a
big big issue which is first of all
there are drugs that uh
that are effective some of which were
developed under operation warp speed
which are the monocle antibodies for
instance if you're a person who's
symptomatic and you're an outpatient and
you're high risk
you should go to get monoclonal
antibodies they decrease the
hospitalization rate by 70 percent
in people who are high risk
that's what the data was um and so
that's that's very important there are
other drugs that are coming out
uh the the biggest issue that you're
getting at probably or
i will make that leap
is that
there was a gross failure
of nih
to do the clinical trials on widely
available cheap
safe drugs that were already fda
approved
like hydroxy chloroquine if your
mechanism these are drugs that have a
mechanism of action it's called
that suggests that they should work
and so
we're two years into a pandemic and
we've still never done these definitive
trials sponsored by the nih the nih is
supposed to do the drug trials
the question is why did they do that i
don't know the answer but i do know that
they inculcated inappropriate fear
in people about hydroxychloroquine
immediately after the president said
prematurely hydroxychloroquine works for
covid
and once that phrase was said there was
a massive pushback again you have to say
it's political uh during the election
year
uh somehow refuting that even though it
wasn't known
and so
like i say there were indications that
it should work in the laboratory there
was some anecdotal data but the nih did
not do
the definitive trials and in fact they
claimed that the they and many people
others claim this drug was a dangerous
drug this is a drug
that is has been given the bill in
billions of doses for 70 years it's fda
approved and it's so safe in many
countries you don't need a prescription
for it's an over-the-counter drug in
other countries in many other countries
um so uh this drug was safe factually
true to be safe but it was
it was distorted by the media and other
so-called experts as being dangerous and
therefore people weren't the reason that
was important is they couldn't even get
people to enroll in the clinical trial
that was started because people were
afraid
they also did something unprecedented
they they outlawed basically uh
prescribing it
doctors always are able to prescribe fda
approved drugs at their discretion for
what they think are
reasonable indications this is the
so-called medicine is an art side of
things and in this instance
and in my view my knowledge it's
unprecedented pharmacists were refusing
to fill the prescription order from
doctors for these drugs even though
these are safe drugs fda approved drugs
uh we see the same thing with with
ivermectin and so uh
whether these drugs work or not there's
plenty of indication of data that
suggests that they work the definitive
trials that people wanted to do the
double-blinded trials etc
were really not fully done but that's a
failure
of the united states public health
agencies the failure to do those studies
is a massive
uh egregious public health failure but
that could have been done in months
in the summer of 2020 spring summer 2020
it could have been done because the
drugs were already fda approved
uh so uh the answer to why
uh is a difficult question that people
ask me uh and i i don't i hate to
attribute motive i don't know it's
speculation but i can say this and this
is one of the issues we're addressing
with this academy
there is a very unhealthy
entanglement
of the control of scientific research by
people in the nih
with the
university scientists who need to do
that get the funding to do their
research so that they get promoted
and that all is intermingled with that's
the only evidence to publishing in the
major journals to get the grant and the
funding it all is like a circular kind
of situation and the people who review
the grants are also the people that
review for the journals
and so there it turns out there's this
really very small cartel
almost that controls everyone's career
and so you may wonder why is it that not
many scientists who depend on nih
funding
spoke out
against some of the things that dr
falchi said well there's one reason
their entire career
hinges on nih grant funding
and so when we see
uh a letter to the editor in the lancet
in february 2020 by a bunch of very
famous virologists
saying it is known in february 2020 that
the virus is natural origin and anyone
who says it could be a lavalier is a
conspiracy theorist this is the
consensus
okay that just should never even be
published in a in a good scientific
journal it's garbage
it was also a lie
and you have to wonder why they did that
because they're smart people
and i'm not sure what the answer to y is
but it was false from the get-go the
intimidation factor though coming from
that was there was an attempt to stop
anybody from saying it could be a lab
leak even though that was about as
common sense as you could get
considering the circumstances
so and of course as things have evolved
it's more and more likely that that is
the case anyway
so uh it's very complicated i'm giving
another long-winded answer but um
this stuff is very difficult to sort out
because it's a very complex world and
it's a very uh
let's say corrupt world the funding of
science the control of the scientific
research and when you have someone who
controls the scientific research
is the same person that controls the
public health policy that is derived
from that research
okay that that's
that's that's uh
that's uh that's not that's not okay i
don't know what the i don't have the
vocabulary to say how bad that is in
polite company
yes sir
a little bit off the
presentation but um
masks
the governor
of virginia
issued an executive order
that as of today
he would leave it to the parents to
decide whether their child should go to
school
with a mask or without a mask
and that was totally ignored by fairfax
county
just
and i i think there's got to be some
sort of critical mass of people
that um
stormed that
case or something i just don't know how
they're going to get around that i mean
if somebody says why the hell with you
governor
what does he do well your question
really is sort of uh
what's going on i think in this country
where there's a
lack of um
understanding of what the law is
uh in a sense and here we have
i'm not gonna i don't have to go through
the details about mass but suffice it to
say that
the scientific data
and simple common sense by the way
says that mass are ineffective that's
factually true
in preventing the spread of of this
virus
and in schools there is data actually
absolute data in florida comparing the
schools that had mask wearing with the
children in schools that didn't have
mass wearing and there was no difference
in the number of covet cases
um
so
the governor of virginia
is
sane and rational that's point number
one
uh point number two is uh
it is completely irrational to force
children to wear masks in schools
uh but what can people do about us the
answer and you know i've always said
people ask me when will this be
for months uh you know when will this be
ever when will the cdc say the pandemic
is over when will dr fauci say we don't
have to do this or that and my answer is
never they're not going to okay we
should we must be past that that's not
the answer to the problem the answer to
the problem is to be critical thinking
adults
to have responsibility
we cannot trust people simply because of
their titles we know that now we're not
in that world anymore so we need to
become critical thinkers make the effort
listen to people who are sensible who
cite data who are consistent in what
they say
look at the numbers yourself it's not
that difficult really i think everything
i said in the presentation is very
simple really
uh and then you are responsible for what
the best decisions are for yourself and
your family and particularly your
children and anybody who abrogates that
responsibility to the state for their
own children i mean i think that's a
frightening place to live frankly
so you know we have to uh it's a
responsibility of the parents to make
the decisions for their children and i
think the governor made a very wise
executive order he didn't forbid people
from wearing masks
all he did was he said it's up to the
parent to decide i'm not sure what kind
of country it is that finds that
unacceptable
one other
quick thing
the academy
but you have a room full of people here
who have listened to this excellent
presentation
what do you want all of us to do as a
result
well uh you know several things number
one um be aware of the existence of this
is all new this is new in in in my view
it's pretty broad uh groundbreaking i
don't see the other universities doing
this
uh my university isn't doing it
um so uh
hillsdale uh is a special kind of place
with a concern for freedom
and common sense and and you know the
the founding principles of the country
and freedom and liberty of course is
what the country was founded on and so
what we can do here as a group is spread
the word
uh contact people at hillsdale if you
want to support this
institute in any way you can whether
it's financial or otherwise uh we're
we're frankly uh
if i may say raising uh funds to get
everything done that needs to be done
here
this is not a one-off this is a
long-term project
we're going to involve some of the best
people there are many people who agree
with me who are very high
uh
quality or high level scientists
academicians thought leaders in related
fields i mean the media is really the
interpreter of science to the public we
need the media at the table here to
figure this out
and so we want this to be more known go
to the websites
see what you can do we're going to have
another event
every say month or two at least we're
going to involve students we're going to
involve
the press
and i would say contact the appropriate
people at hillsdale
to see if if you can support we need
people's support to really make this as
impactful as possible
and we have time for one more question
all right
thanks
you'll hold on to it okay um so i'm
gonna i i agreed with almost everything
you said but i'm gonna prove your point
that scientists sometimes disagree a
little bit
and uh and just
and i don't disagree completely but i
want to challenge you a little bit on
something so
uh when it so i i agree 100 that people
at high risk and the elderly should have
been the ones we focused on with
protection and that that's who should
have gotten the vaccines however
i am concerned about some of the data
you presented related to the vaccine
effectiveness on severe disease and
death and i'm just going to give you a
few things to think about you can
comment on
so one issue with that data as i've
looked at it is there's some inherent
bias in that epidemiologic data because
there are many people who
are at high risk
who would also be much less likely to
become vaccinated so
whether it's drug abuse alcoholism maybe
they have a
cancer and they're very immunosuppressed
so the doctor wouldn't even bother
trying the vaccine various types of
things like that
which obviously uh could have could skew
the data in one way or the other i think
the danish study you showed where you
saw the largest drop in effectiveness
dealt with that um to some degree
because they actually matched
the demographics of the people in that
study so i think that's actually one of
the best studies that's been done
my other concern is the time
in that these are all snapshot studies
and what we know about rna respiratory
viruses is they're constantly changing
as we've seen with the various variants
and now omicron and i believe that and
there's actually data now there's danish
data and if you look at israel um you
see that over time
larger and larger percentages of people
who are fully vaccinated sometimes
boosted are making up those hospitalized
and uh and um and severe disease and
deaths and so i think that when we end
up looking at this over the longer
period of time of the whole sort of
episode whether it's the pandemic or
even as we move into an endemic period
we are going to see that that vaccine
effectiveness against severe disease and
death over the long haul will continue
to drop off just as the effectiveness
against cases drops off because of the
way this works so again i'm not saying
it doesn't work at all i think it was
very useful and had we targeted the
right populations early on it would have
been very effective because we would
have allowed other people to develop
natural immunity that could have ended
up
making this move faster to an endemic
level but i i do worry about some of
that data that's just 80 90 percent
effectiveness against severe disease
over the long haul because i just don't
think those numbers are going to hold up
yeah well i mean i i would say it's
absolutely true and i i try to say this
in various ways is that
this is very short term we don't know
what's going to happen i completely
agree uh we we
of course think that there's going to be
some drop-off in all of the protections
over time that's what we're seeing
there's a trend toward that
but
what we have is what we have
and so
at this point in time
my point of showing those slides is not
that a vaccine is 90 effective against
stopping death
it doesn't have to be to be worth taking
uh if you're a high-risk person
uh you know that's a
heck of a lot better than what the flu
vaccine does for the same people
okay when you look at the data on the
flu vaccine and the people who die from
the flu besides the young children are
the same elderly and firm
people
and when you look at the efficacy
there's a lot of question about how how
well of how effective the flu vaccines
are not just because the flu virus
changes this virus changes too uh but
you're right i mean the bottom line is i
agree with you the story needs to play
out we don't know
but if somebody but what i hate to see
is the uh sort of
uh confusion that people have
that are high risk that because you get
in very poor protection against an
infection
with a mild disease that means you don't
that the vaccine doesn't work at all
i'm very concerned with that i think
that's a that's a misconception
uh in terms of so far it looks pretty
good at protecting death it's against
death
it's probably true that it's going to
wane it didn't wane in the sweden data
we know that and i happen to trust the
sweden data
and so of course we'll see over time
uh but it's not clear to me
what with the story will be written uh
how the story will be written because
now we know with omicron and so many
people who have been vaccinated that got
the infection
that the data on uh the smaller
percentage of people in the end who had
the vaccine but never infected
i'm not even sure a lot of those people
won't have had the infection
because the infection is so commonly
asymptomatic and i think that is another
contaminant of all these studies they
never prove these people never had the
infection
when they categorize people who's
vaccinated but uninfected they mean
they'd have never had the symptoms of
covet or a positive covalent test
doesn't mean they never had the
infection
half the cases are asymptomatic and with
omicron probably
more so you're right there's still uh
the vaccine story is not fully written i
agree i just think it's um it's a
problem if people have
jumped to saying
the vaccines don't work i i don't agree
with that statement so far
let's see what happens
okay thank you very much
nothing
you